plein jour dans le stationnement
du centre commercial Rockland.
- À l'Hôpital Pierre-Boucher,
une cellule de crise nationale
ouverte depuis la découvertedu ,
le Candida auris.
la même chambre ont été infectés
depuis lbre.
Trois autres patients ayant
eu des contacts éten cours d'in.
Ce microscopique champignon
s'attaque aux malades
à l'immunité affaiblie.LAY, CHUM
microbiologiste-infectiologue
- Ils peuvent causer
des infections, en général ce
l'immunité est affaiblie. Soit
parce qu'ils ont une grave
maladie, qu'ils sont aux soins
d'imunosuppression au départ.
se défendent moins
bien. Ils peuvent causer des
infectio
comme une infection de peau,
mais ils peuvent c
des infections systémiques
et dans ce cas-là, le tauxlité e
assez élevé.
- Une personne infectée a
de 30 à 60 % de risques
de mouri DUFRESNE, médecin
spécialiste maladies infect.- U,
ça peut être difficile de s'en
débarrasser. Donc, c'est pour
limiter le plus vite possible.
MICHAËL ROCHELEAU, représentant
national Syndicat APTS
- Il y a plus de travail
à faire, il y a beaucoup pl
du Candida auris, en fait,
c'est sûr que ça
une charge de travail
supplémentaire.
- Du côté du CISSole
précise que :
L'éclosion a été confirmée
le 20 septembre, mais ce n'estqd
que l'ensemble des employés
en ont été informés.
un mystère, mais le ministre
fédéral de la Santé, se dit
préoccupé.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS,
ministre fédéral de la Santé
préoccupe beaucoup de gens
depuis quelque temps et qui
préoccupe aussi et qui préoccupe
la santé publique fédérale
et je leur ai demandé
- L'Institut national de santé
publique du Québeciséiséiséiséié
dans ce dossier, aux côtés
du ministère de la Santé
et des Services so
Radio-Canada, Mon